this video is brought to you by blinkers
look it's not always easy to find the
time to sit down and read all of the
books you want I'm a pretty busy dude so
I understand that and I don't read
nearly as much as I used to or as much
as I would want to but good news is I
have this blink estab which is an app
that you can download and it basically
just gives you 15 minute summaries of
all the best non-fiction books me I
actually listen to most of them because
as well as having written summaries they
also have audio versions which are
fantastic I basically just listen to
these in the moments in the day when I'm
like you know commuting to work or doing
the dishes stuff like that is when I
grab a listen to a quick clip from
Linkous 8 million people currently using
this app and it really does provide the
best insights from thousands of books on
here right now I've just been going
through again Stephen our cubbies the
seven Habits of Highly Effective People
I actually read the book a while ago
been using Linkous to get up-to-date on
it I've also got coming up with shark I
haven't read either of these but I'm
looking forward to the blinks is James
Donovan's shoot for the moon and
Gabrielle Weinberg and Lauren McCann's
super thinking so I'm gonna be checking
those out check out the seven Habits
that's a great one the first a hundred
people to go to blink is calm
forward-slash visual politic we'll get
one week to try it out you also get 25%
off if you go for the full membership
again that's a 7 day trial that you can
cancel at any time just go to blinkers
comm forward slash visual politic or
click the link in the description below
and let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
on paper they should be great allies
something like Batman and Robin or Frodo
and Sam but of international politics
hedonist or the Russia a dig in a
[Music]
[Applause]
let me explain Japan and South Korea are
relatively free countries in a
geopolitical environments that has some
very unusual conditions they share
partners face the same threats and have
strong economic ties sounds like a
pretty good match but here's more
we're talking about two countries that
have the same strategic Ally the United
States which currently has a total of
eighty thousand soldiers deployed in
Japan and Korea virtually full Army in
addition both countries face the same
challenges and the same threats mainly
an aging population as well as growing
economic political and military weight
from both North Korea and China and
that's not all
with bilateral trade that exceeds 80
billion dollars per year and a transit
of more than ten million tourists Japan
and South Korea's economies are very
interrelated so as you can see they take
all of the boxes to be very good friends
what's more together South Korea and
Japan form a much stronger bloc than you
could imagine we're talking about a
block that has a hundred and seventy
seven million inhabitants an industrial
production that doubles that of Germany
and is five times that of France and it
has the third largest military budget on
the entire planet standing just behind
the United States and China together
they spend more than ninety billion
dollars each year on defense
in other words if you had to work as
consultants for these two governments
you're surely advise them to strengthen
their ties and work side by side right
well just a second because theory is one
thing that the reality is something
altogether different the truth is that
Japan and South Korea really do not get
along and that explains news stories
like this incident causes a surge in
tension between South Korea and Japan
forget North Korea is the next showdown
in Asia Japan versus South Korea and now
more than ever this topic is a hot one
need some proof I'll check this out
according to a study conducted in July
of 2019
no less than 74 percent of Japanese
people reported a distrust of South
Koreans and apparently the feeling is
mutual 75 percent of South Koreans
distrust the Japanese but of course it
doesn't end there at the beginning of
July 2019 the Japanese government's
unleashed a sort of trade war against
South Korea more specifically it
restricted the exports of freaky
products to South Korean industry
chlorinated polyamide hydrogen fluoride
and photo protectors
okay so you might never have heard of
these things but we're talking about
three chemicals that are essential for
manufacturing things such as
semiconductors and smartphone screens
and these are two components of which
South Korea is one of the largest
manufacturers and exporters on the
planet in fact we could say that
semiconductors up something like South
Korea's oil South Korea is the world
leader when it comes to chip making and
Japan is a world leader in the
manufacturing of key materials for chip
making on kihyun vice president of the
korea semiconductor industry association
and no it doesn't in there either at the
beginning of august
japan announced new restrictions which
may not be the last but before we
continue I think we need to ask
ourselves some questions what exactly is
going on
why did Japan unleash such a conflict
with one of its biggest trading partners
what consequences could it have
[Music]
the reconciliation that never arrives to
understand the entire story we need to
go back to the beginning of the 20th
century from 1910 until the end of World
War two in 1945 Korea was a Japanese
colony these weren't exactly happy years
for the Koreans the Japanese Empire
ruled Korea with an iron fist
there was a great deal of repression a
large amount of crimes were committed
and many lands were de facto expropriate
errs to give you an idea while the South
Korean people went hungry lots of the
agricultural production was sent to
Japan and there's more during the
Japanese occupation hundreds of
thousands of South Koreans were forcibly
recruited to work in brutal Semmy
slavery conditions in Japanese industry
and mines Stanford University estimates
that this included more than 700,000
South Koreans but here this is horrible
well hold on because things are about to
get even worse during World War two tens
of thousands of South Korean women were
forced to practice the oldest trade in
the world in order to satisfy Japanese
soldiers it's estimated the between
50,000 and 200,000 women were victims of
this atrocity this all explains why
seven decades later Japan and South
Korea continued to fight over what the
occupation meant a local government near
Seoul is calling for all Japanese made
school products to be affixed with a
sticker saying they were made by quote
war criminals of course in South Korea
regained its independence in 1945 there
have been several attempts to reconcile
and hand the page the two most important
ones happened in 1965 and 2015 and both
had the same results
[Music]
you see in 1965 when South Korea was a
dictatorship led by Park chung-hee both
countries agreed to end all disputes
Japan assumed its responsibility and
promised to pay the South Korean
government's the equivalent of 2.4
billion dollars as compensation and
another 1.6 billion in low-interest
loans so was everything sorted well no
in 2012 South Korea's Supreme Court
recognized the victims right to obtain
individual compensation and not from the
Japanese government but from the
Japanese companies that were involved in
the forced labor cases the fact is that
in 2018 the South Korean supreme court's
ruling led companies such as Nippon
Steel Mitsubishi Heavy Industries and
the Nazi Party Koshi corporation to pay
between 70,000 and 90,000 dollars to
each of the two dozen victims who'd made
a claim at the courts and that's where
it all really lies the ruling ordered
compensation for the victims of their
living relatives because of course some
had already passed away and here lies
the heart of the matter can you imagine
if the same thing happens with all of
the other forced workers living or dead
if their families could make a claim
today we'll be talking about
compensation amounting to billions of
dollars which of course Japan has no
intention of paying because among other
things from their point of view this
whole issue has already been resolved by
the 1965 agreements on the other hands
in 2015 both governments agreed that
Japan would create a fund of about 9
million dollars to compensate the women
who were enslaved during World War two
but you know what this agreement it was
also worthless why well listen up
[Music]
the bigger fire strategy the South
Korean economy is not going so great
right now we've talked about it here on
visual politic previously and I'll leave
a link to that video in the description
since moon jae-in came to power things
have been unravelling almost as fast as
snapchat photos disappear and of course
the president's own popularity has
followed closely behind the economy
according to polls moon jae-in's
approval dropped from 83 percent in May
of 2018 to 45 percent just a year later
and not only that this is also a time
when economic affairs are gaining more
and more power the South Korean leaders
economic management plummeted down to 30
percent and well here's a question for
you what do you do if you have a huge
fire but you want people to look the
other way well you make an even bigger
fire I didn't make that up it is truly
one of the oldest tricks in all of
politics
[Music]
and that's exactly what wound Ryan seems
to be doing pouring gasoline onto
another fire now this doesn't actually
seem to have been too hard because since
he reached power in 2017 monde Ryan has
always been focused on Japan in fact one
of his first actions was to announce the
unilateral and retroactive suspension of
the 2015 agreement and since then
tensions between the two countries
they've only grown on some examples well
check this out in the last year we've
witnessed increasingly controversial and
almost provocative political statements
from the South Korean government against
Japan further South Korean intelligence
has stopped sharing the information it
has with Japan in December 2018
according to Japanese sources a South
Korean frigate set its shooting radar on
a Japanese plane shortly after Seoul
prevented Japanese Defense Force ships
from using its ports and even as
recently as the beginning of 2019 we've
seen a boycott on the purchase of
Japanese products which was instigated
by the South Korean government itself so
if what he's looking for is a fight the
South Korean president couldn't be doing
a better job my lateral relationship
right now is about as bad as it has ever
been and it is continuing to deteriorate
onion Hey
professor of international relations at
Korea University the point is that moon
jaein didn't think that Japan would
respond with such strength well maybe he
did
[Music]
Trump opens the door Japan walks right
in Donald Trump was a pioneer of this
tactic using Commerce as a launching
weapon in international political
negotiations now Japan has gone one step
further they are using the trade war to
punish an allied man has had enough and
Shinzo our they can't deal with it
anymore
he thinks that the South Korean issue
wins all their pending quarrels have
gone too far
the 1965 agreements the apologies of
1990 1991 and the 2015 agreements Tokyo
they're not willing to make any more
concessions now of course the fact that
the Prime Minister himself is considered
revisionist doesn't help we also talked
about that rather recently in another
video the fact is that at the beginning
of July
the Japanese government decided to
punish Korea with restrictions on the
three components we mentioned before
fluorinated polyamide hydrogen fluoride
and photo protectors we're talking about
a measure that if not reverse soon could
cause great problems for some South
Korean giants like Samsung or SK Hynix
to have the world's largest
semiconductor manufacturers at the
beginning of August the Japanese
government communicated its decision to
remove South Korea from its white list
of 27 countries that have preferential
commercial status basically the
countries on this list can buy most
Japanese technology and products freely
and without restrictions this means that
to buy practically any product except
food and wood South Korean companies
will have to comply with the Japanese
government's approval process which not
only involves more bureaucracy and
import costs it also means the Japanese
government now has the right end of the
stick there is they can veto any sale to
South Korea at will
[Music]
and this is something that given the
deep commercial relations between the
two countries could be a hard blow to
Korea
[Music]
[Applause]
and not only it for Korea but also for
Japan which has a trade surplus with its
neighbor of more than 20 billion dollars
[Music]
the official excuse that South Korea
can't guarantee that all these products
and technology exports with possible
military use won't reach North Korea as
an example hydrogen fluoride isn't only
used in semiconductor production it can
also be used for uranium enrichment or
to manufacture sarin gas although this
sounds like a bit of an excuse of course
the real reason is the endless
controversy that surrounds this happy
colonial past Japanese accusations are
very serious we have not provided
evidence of any collusion between South
Korea and North Korea so far saline
popcorn the Japan expert at the French
Institute for international relations
[Music]
of course at this point the question we
have to ask is does it make sense to
resort to commercial warfare as a
foreign policy weapon well the truth is
that experience and evidence say no you
see now the South Korean government
isn't only responding with its own
sanctions they're also putting a lot of
money on the table to reduce their
dependence on Japanese companies in a
way it's similar to what happens with
China in 2011 back then the Chinese
government restricted the sale of rare
lands to Japan and well what do you
think the Japanese did they invested in
their own mines in the end China's
market share decreased in Japanese
taxpayers better to pay for it that is
the outcome was just bad for everyone so
yes this time Shinzo our base shot might
backfire again anyway what is most
likely is that Japan and Korea will
sooner or later return to the starting
point and continue this endless spiral
of grievances you know what it would be
really good if they could just settle
this matter once and for all
the block
a close alliance between South Korea and
Japan would frankly be a very good thing
they would form an economic and
political bloc with a great deal of
influence for example that have free
trade with China which Japan and South
Korea are jointly negotiating progress
is slowed down now with moon jaein but
once it is settled it will create an
even wider area for trade this would be
great for everyone
on a political level that become a
beacon in an area of the world that is
full of dictatorships and at a military
level they'd be able to offset China's
weight
but of course to achieve all this is
absolutely necessary that both
governments reach an agreement once and
for all leave the past behind and focus
on the future
so I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do smash that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also please do check
out our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast who provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine this channel
is also possible because of patreon and
our patrons on that platform please
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]